[Music]
right guess what everyone in my house is
going vegetarian so
you know on stage night it can be a
lonely night so i've had to make some
really smart adjustments and this dish
has been inspired by my time in
california this is an amazing
cauliflower steak that will be on your
table in literally 10 minutes quicker
than you can say the word vegan right
oscar pan down
beautiful cauliflower we're going to
take the steak the center cut and the
rest will use for cauliflower and cheese
soup puree whatever you want to do or
even a cauliflower couscous but that
middle steak is the money shot beautiful
onions caraway seeds parsley shallots
garlic dill mint
sugar
beautiful mustard and like i heard the
provence because we're gonna make
a sort of fresh salsa verde
but first things first
let's get that steak on let's have 10
minutes on the clock please
now
hot pan
gas up
cauliflower steak
doesn't sound original
but this is going to transform the way
you eat cauliflower
put a little mark there a little mark
that side and what i'm trying to do is
make sure i get that beautiful
steak in the center
save that for later
keep that on there and look i want to
come down
about an inch thick
and go all the way through
and look
that is what i want a beautiful
steak
now
gently place that down
these little bits of cauliflower
trust me great
for coffee and cheese and bacon etc
soups purees now
let's get some all in the pan okay get
the gas up
okay i want to give
some really nice flavor to this
cauliflower
gently lift it up
as it starts to smoke
in she goes
lay away from you
keep that down there gotta get some
color on that no color no flavor even
when i'm talking about cauliflower salt
cracked pepper
and then let's get some aromats in there
some garlic doesn't need to be peeled
just literally
crushed
and in
now
gently
get color on that
next pan it's gonna be a dry pan i'm
gonna toast our spices we've got some
caraway seeds
going in
okay
some almonds going in and this is sort
of a nice
sort of fragrant toast
a nice seasoning and gives it a really
nice sort of beautiful flavor i'm going
to put a little pinch
of caraway in the bottom of the pan
i'm getting some color on that now give
it a little shake
gently lift that up you just start to
see
the color how do we get more color on
there
little knobs of butter okay
that's like a really nice flavor
i've got the garlic sort of working its
magic
from there
look
that smells incredible
now
literally
lemon
in
lemon juice helps to keep it nice and
white but also just roasting that in
there the sort of lemon starts to puree
and this cauliflower starts to become a
little bit more fragrant
i'm toasting my
seeds here
a flavor that smells incredible
now also got the color
on the cauliflower steak literally lift
that up
turn that over
turn down the gas
add a touch of water or stock in
bring
that back up to the boil instantly as it
starts boiling put that lid on
and then turn that gas down time please
seven minutes
beautiful
now
from there i'm going to take out my
beautiful
almonds and chloe see just let them
toast and sit
that's beautiful it smells incredible
now
for the salsa verde
okay it's a very sort of
acidic
delicious
garnish and it's almost
better than the garnish because it's
quite substantial
i'm going to chop up the shallots
not too fine
okay
beautifully done
all the way down to the root
and then look
into the bowl
now
from there take your mint
and take your dill
and take your parsley
and scrunch it up
almost like a big
fat cigar
now just chop the herbs once
i say once because i want the freshness
left in the herb sometimes when you over
chop herbs the board turns green
i want the green and the flavor in the
salsa verde look my board's clean look
really important
because
when you slice something
it starts to bleed and i want it
bleeding sort of almost flavor coming
out of those herbs into the salsa verde
salt pepper
and this is where it starts to go up
a different level a nice tablespoon of
mustard
a nice tablespoon of brown sugar
two tablespoons of red wine vinegar
in and then
the olive oil
now the olive oil don't go crazy olive
oil
mix that
up
and sort of keep it quite dense and
thick
you never really have a salsa verde that
is literally
runny
it's quite a nice beautiful
chunky thick rich liquid
and then of course
your beautiful dried herbs
now i know they're fresh and dried herbs
in there but as the dry herbs start
to sort of rehydrate inside
it opens up this amazing
amount of flavor
the sugar gives it the sweetness
the vinegar gives it the tartness and
the olive oil gives that celta verde a
really nice rich
texture from there
that's so good
take some of my almonds
and my seeds and just crunch them up
into there save some on top
and beautifully
beautifully mix them in
now i need a bit of a sheen this can be
served as a wonderful sort of side dish
or an actual main course
time please four minutes
and look
that's what i want i want that really
nice
picant
salsa verde
[Music]
beautiful now
check the cauliflower
now
here's where the magic is
the gas is down
the idea now is coating that steak i've
got the smell of the garlic the lemon
and the bay leaves in there
take off that lid oh
oh
that smell beautiful
i touch more butter
and this is where it starts to sort of
work its magic
i'm going to whack up the gas
okay
and this is like almost what we call a
fondant
and the word fondon comes from a sheen
and we're sort of now glazing tilting
the pan and glazing this beautiful
cauliflower steak
[Music]
and the flavor
is incredible
turn that gas up
check the seasoning
oh lovely
touch more
salt some beautiful
fresh black pepper
and then look
i'll take my
lemon out
and just squeeze
a beautiful juice
over that cauliflower
the smell is incredible
get your small knife and it should
literally just be going through the
steak and look it's just going through
and that
tells you it's beautifully cooked
from there
one more final glaze
now i'm reducing that down the butter
the olive oil the seasoning
the bay leaves the garlic push all them
back
off with the gas
and this
steak
comes home to rest
look at that
that sits on
the middle of your plate
this juice in here
is incredible
glaze the steak with your juice
and then
get this beautiful
salsa verde
i want it fresh
so i want to sort of
macerate that over and let it seep
through
now i don't sit down and easily eat this
for sort of three or four minutes
because i want that salsa verde to sort
of penetrate
and go through
from top to the bottom that incredible
beautiful steak
fresh
extra virgin olive oil
and then my seeds
my beautiful toasted almonds
now that is so good a beautiful
cauliflower steak in under 10 minutes
honestly tonight
it makes me want to turn vegetarian
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsey
intent cookbook inspired by this series
and trust me you're gonna come out a
much better chef and if you like this
video don't forget to subscribe to my
amazing youtube channel for more good
luck
you